Galpin: So the title
of the presentation
is "Evading Pirates
and Stopping Vampires
Using License Server,
In-app Billing, and App Engine."
Now you might ask,
"Okay, what do these
three things have in common?
License Server, In-app Billing,
and App Engine."
And they're all technologies
that we're providing
that allow you to take
some form of your application
and put it into the Cloud.
In this case,
the way your application
protects itself from pirates
as well as the way we validate
that protection
is now all being put in some
form or another in the Cloud.
But let's talk first
about pirates.
So piracy is a reality
on all platforms,
and really dedicated pirates
aren't going to be stopped,
which is why this talk is not
titled "Stopping Pirates,"
because we recognize that--
that, uh, ultimately people
are very, uh,
they're--they're--
ultimately people are--
are going to be
very, very dedicated
to trying to--
to the craft of hacking.
But what we want to do
is not necessarily
target these people.
Let them have fun.
But let's target
these guys instead.
Yeah, we all know--
we all know
what these pirates look like.
You know, the regular pirates
are, you know--
have the eye patch, and they're
green, and, you know, they--
but these guys here
are the guys we really want
because these guys
are our potential customers.
So why do stuff like make piracy
a little inconvenient
or challenging
or message that it's uncool?
You know, we can use the fact
that people are downloading our
application as a marketing tool.
It doesn't necessarily
have to be something
where someone comes up
and they just can't
play anything
and they can't see anything.
That doesn't help us ultimately.
Um, we want to make sure
that people recognize
that there's great content
out there.
And of course, we want to
leverage new monetization models
around things like
In-App purchase and Ads.
So how many of you were at
the Android Market talk
earlier today?
So one of the things
that's kind of amazing
is that we've now
put up a list
of top-grossing applications
on Android Market.
Now what's shocking about that
is that out of the top five
top-grossing applications
three of them are solely funded
through In-App Payments,
and we've only introduced
In-App Payments a month ago.
So this is something
that is working.
So again,
if you have something like this
when you--
when a license check fails,
there's a good chance
this is not going to do
anything valuable for you.
Okay, your customer
is going to get annoyed.
Even worse, if this comes up
when they've legitimately
purchased the app,
they're gonna be really upset.
Although actually I-I would find
that kind of cool.
But, uh...
[laughter]
Galpin: But--but there are ways
in which we can approach this,
again, as a marketing tool.
So--so think about this
as we go through
this presentation.
But let's talk first about what
License Verification Library is.
It is your first defense
against piracy.
And what's cool about it
is that it is not a system
that is cookie-cutter system
that every application uses
in the same way,
and this is intentional,
because the goal is that
someone should not be able
to write a tool
that removes this kind
of protection from your app,
where if they write that tool
it's got to be really,
really complicated,
because it's going
to have to attack
all sorts of different ways
you can protect yourself.
And that's really the goal here.
So how does this work?
The application
actually determines
how to enforce the policy.
You get to create
the dialog that comes up.
the messaging around it.
You get to use it, again, as
a marketing tool if you want to.
In fact, you can simply say,
"Hey, man,
I've got kids at home,
and, you know, I make
my living off of this."
And you can do
whatever you want.
You don't have to be
the bad guy
or seem like the bad guy,
'cause, of course, you're not.
You're developers.
Um, and the way this works
is by using public key--
public key cryptog--
public key cryptography.
So we store the private key
up in our server,
and your application
actually verifies the license,
the signed license response
from our server.
Let's talk about how
this actually works--
so once again,
private key up in our server,
which is actually
Android Market,
and public key
in your application.
When you want to verify
the license, your application
simply sends a "check license
request" message
off to the licensing service.
It goes to the server.
It comes back down.
And blam, you get
a signed response.
Sounds pretty cool.
The nice thing about this
is that it has nothing to do
with the platform.
They can be running whatever
kind of code they want.
They can be running
a routed system.
They can be running another,
you know--
whatever they've put on there
it doesn't matter,
because your application
and the server
are the only
two trusted components.
That was obviously done
by design.
But there is one problem
with this
in that there is
a well-known client attack.
And here's what people do.
They use tools
to disassemble the code,
and they make simple changes in
the code to alter the response
so that instead of returning
the licensed or unlicensed,
it alters it.
They reassemble it. They sign
it with an alternate signature.
And blam,
protection is broken.
So we realized that
was going to be an issue.
In fact, when we first
released it we suggested
doing a couple of things
in order to help strengthen
the defenses
of your application.
And since then we've come up
with a couple of more ideas,
and I'll share a few of those
with you.
So the first
and most important thing
is to use an obfuscator,
and it's gonna make it harder
for someone to understand your
code when it's disassembled.
The second thing we want to do
is to actually modify the LVL.
The LVL is simply an example,
and of course,
there's always a problem
whenever you give
an example to someone,
is that there is
a tremendous, tremendous desire
to want to use it verbatim,
no matter how bad it is,
and I've seen this
in--in every aspect
of my software engineering
career,
and the LVL is no exception.
It it truly just an example
of how to call this service
that's with an Android Market,
but it is not
in any way designed
to be the beyond
and all of piracy protection,
so we modify it.
And we also,
and most importantly,
we make the application
tamper-resistant.
We want the application
to know
if the user has touched it,
if the user's re-signed it,
if the user's done
something to it
that is going to change its
behavior, for a lot of reasons.
I mean, we want people
to not be cheating in games
in Android Market either.
So there's a lot of reasons
to make your application
tamper-resistant.
And the nice thing about
the tamper-resistant stuff
is it doesn't matter.
It is not relying on the LVL.
It is entirely independent
of what goes on in LVL.
So let's talk about
invocation/response handling.
One of the things
that the LVL does wrong
is it invokes itself
in onCreate,
which is a logical place
if you want to invoke something
like this.
After all, your activity's
being created right then.
It's very, very obvious.
The problem with that
is it's very obvious
to anyone who's trying
to hack your code
that that's where
you would put it,
and it's always going
to happen at the same time,
during start-up,
so it's very easy to trap.
So it's much, much better
to put in a function,
first of all, that's obfuscated,
that--that isn't called
by the framework,
and secondly, doing it
in a background thread.
Doing it at some random time
makes it a lot harder to trap.
Finally, again,
allowing for a limited amount
of game play is kind of cool.
I mean, first of all, it becomes
an immediate marketing tool,
and, uh, and secondly, you know,
it--it actually gives you
the ability to recover nicely.
Like, if the user actually has
to wait for that license check
at the beginning
of every single game,
you're inconveniencing
all of your legitimate users,
and that's not fun either.
Um, definitely this third one
is super, super important,
and we might even see a result
of that in this session,
because we're gonna be demoing
a couple of license check stuff,
and you'll see, especially
in a room like this
where there's not gonna be
a lot of Wi-Fi issues probably
or network issues,
it's very possible
these checks are gonna fail.
And so you're gonna want
to make sure
that the failure you get, um,
it's actually not
just "license failed,"
but it's "license failed
because the user is unlicensed,"
not failed because
the network is down.
'Cause that--
there's nothing worse
than trying to launch a game
when you're on a plane,
getting an unlicensed response
and then saying,
"Sorry, you're gonna be bored
for the next eight hours
because of this."
Again, we don't want
to inconvenience
our legitimate users
as much as possible.
And then finally,
another thing we can do
is rather than just
chaining off our code
and going and invoking
something like a dialog,
which is very,
very easy to spot,
invoke another activity
that actually does it for us.
It makes it a lot harder
to track how that happened.
Okay, here is the core logic
in the existing LVL,
and there are a lot of problems
with this core logic.
Um, one of them--
well, I'll--
I'll go through them.
Uh, first of all, let's go
through some updated code.
So first of all this looks
a little different.
Now one is that
we are not using
simple values like 0 and 1 to
mean licensed or not licensed.
We're actually taking
those values.
We're performing some sort of
transform on them so it's harder
to see in the assembly code
what's going on.
The second thing we're doing
is we're actually shoving
a bunch of code in between,
and the reason why
we're doing this
is that it makes it
a lot harder to see,
"All right, well,
there's that...
Now what are they doing
with that value?"
You've got to actually follow it
through the code.
Even better if it's an--
ultimately a different function,
or it's handled somewhere else,
as long as it's being
stopped somewhere.
So that's a really simple thing
you can do.
Again, the idea--make it harder
for any simple tools
in order to crack
your application.
Tamper resistance--this is
actually my favorite part.
Um, so the first thing
you can do
and the easiest thing
is to check to make sure your
application signature matches--
now the signature
is actually the thing
that's on your certificate
that is used
to sign the application--
so it does remain consistent
between different builds
of your application,
and that can be done just by
going to the Package Manager
and calling "get signatures,"
returning in this case
the first one.
Pretty simple.
In this case I am actually
hashing the signature.
Kind of nice--
you aren't storing a big string
that's obvious
in the application.
We're just storing an integer.
That's pretty straightforward.
That way if someone re-signs it
we can immediately tell.
Um, we also want to make sure
it's not debuggable, you know,
because if it is we probably
want to do something different.
It makes it harder for someone
to track using the debugger.
So that's easy to do, too.
We can CRC code files
and compare.
Now this sounds like it's gonna
be really expensive to do--
I mean, you have to go through
all of your code files--
but it turns out that
all of your--all of your files
are actually CRC'ed for you
because they're all inside of
zip packages inside of the APK.
So we can just
take advantage of that.
In this case now we have it.
We've now in, you know,
four lines of code,
CRC'ed all of our source files,
and we've gotten the value
for that,
and so we can check to see
if our Dalvik files
have been changed.
So another thing we can do if we
want to go farther with this--
and this is kind of nice
because it uses
a completely different API--
is we can check to see if
our whole certificate matches.
So this is just using the fact
that--that actually APK files
are very similar to JAR files,
and you can use
these same functions
which are part of our framework
in order to actually pull
the certificates out.
So one more thing you can do.
Now, again,
this is all pretty basic stuff.
Another thing you might want
to consider
is actually adding reflection.
Reflection is definitely
something you can do
to obfuscate your code.
It can also make
your code easier to hack,
so we have to be careful
when we use this.
So let's look at
our previous example,
which gets the hash
of the first signature.
Now we can implement this
using reflection
in a couple of different ways.
One of the things
that I'm doing here
is I'm actually Base64 encoding
the strings that I'm using
for reflection,
again, making it harder to track
what's going on
in the actual source code.
The other thing that I'm doing
is obviously this is--
there's gonna be no linkage
inside of the application
that says we're actually
calling something
in the Package Manager.
And this is actually important,
because pretty much
any of the tools that people
are using to analyze APKs
are watching for calls
to the Package Manager.
That's--that's--that's--
they recognize
that people are using
these things already.
So this is actually
a really good way
of making--making those tools
much, much harder to write,
making it much, much harder
for your applications
to get compromised.
Another thing we can do
is actually add native code.
So if you happen to have
a native module,
you can write that same thing
that I did--
that I showed before,
looking something like this.
Now, okay, admittedly
this is a lot of code,
but that's because this is
actually a combination of using
reflection and JNI,
and the first section of it
actually is really
the reflective part.
And all we're doing is getting
the IEDs for all our functions
and our objects,
and you really only do this once
when the application starts.
And the code that actually does
the checking itself
looks like that,
so pretty straightforward.
Again, it's very similar.
We're just calling
a couple of methods in here.
Of course, obfuscating
is important.
We've actually added support
for ProGuard
into the latest version
of the tools.
But we realized that
there was a problem in the LVL
that made it very difficult
to obfuscate what was going on.
So anyone who's actually using
an obfuscator
should make this change.
So what we were doing
is we were actually
binding to the service based
upon the class
that was actually
inside of the LVL,
which means when the obfuscator
went and changed that class name
everything didn't work.
And in fact there's
an elaborate work-around
in the ProGuard file
that comes with
the current, uh, SDK.
But the good news
is that in fact you can remove
that work-around
and change this
to something else.
And again, now we've got
a string there
that makes it really obvious,
so we should transform
that string somehow,
again, use something.
I-I don't necessarily
suggest Base64--
That's kind of obvious--
but there are a lot of ways
we can transform that string
so it's much, much harder
for when someone's
looking for the code
to figure out where
we're actually doing the check.
All right, another thing
we can do
is actually put the entire check
into C/C++ code,
again, taking advantage
of the fact
that our application
is actually a zip file.
So what we've done here
is--okay, sorry.
This is a little different.
Um... [laughs]
This is--this is actually
CRC'ing classes.
This is the same example
we had before.
CRC'ing classes
taking advantage of the fact
that it's a zip file,
once again using JNI.
But what's kind of cool
is we can actually go
a little farther than this,
and we can actually go and use
some publicly available
libraries that are out there,
and this on--in this case
we're using MiniZip
to do the exact same thing.
And this line of code,
when placed within the right
part of the MiniZip library,
will actually,
entirely in need of code,
allow you to check the CRC
of your main classes file.
And this--this is great
because it means
that they're not gonna have
anything in Dalvik to look for
when they're trying
to figure out
how to hack your application.
They're actually have to go
modify the native library.
It's, again, one more step that
they're gonna have to take.
It makes it
just that much harder
for them to work around
all of this.
Finally, if you are going
to call native code
within your application,
consider registering your native
signatures from your class file
with "javap-s,"
um, using this register native
method function.
And we're gonna talk about this
a little bit in the next session
we're doing,
which is on "C and C++
Bringing Games to Android,"
but I just want--I thought
I'd mention this here
because it's very, very useful.
Because by registering
your methods manually
rather than dynamically,
it makes the name--
it means you can control
what the names are going to be,
and ultimately that makes it
just that much harder to track,
'cause the standard names
that are giving by JNI
are very, very easy to see.
Anyone can look at your library
and see where
those entry points are.
This just hides them
a little bit more.
And, of course,
we can go further.
Um, I'm not gonna get
into these kinds of things.
We can actually store things
as encrypted resources.
We can use the class loader.
There's all sorts of crazy stuff
you can do in Dalvik,
and I definitely recommend
looking at it.
This is kind of fun.
Um, you know,
eventually we do have
kind of
diminishing returns here.
Um, most of the things
that I talked about here
can be implemented in literally
just a few hours of work,
and if after you've spent months
working on your title,
it makes a lot of sense to take
those few hours of work
because it does actually,
believe it or not, help.
And we've seen this with several
applications on Market
that have taken
these kinds of techniques,
and they have improved
their ability
to protect against piracy.
But there's something even worse
than pirates...
and that is, well, vampires.
And here's what I mean
when I say "vampires."
Games and other titles
often have server components,
and sometimes Android games
have asset downloads,
'cause they're really big.
But if someone runs
your title unauthorized,
they are sucking your bandwidth,
and that costs you money.
So what we can do
is we can actually stop vampires
by making sure our servers
actually understand
how this whole system works...
and the way we can do this
is fairly straightforward.
So remember I showed you
that slide earlier
talking about how we did
client side validation.
Well, the server side validation
is pretty much the same thing.
Public key is in
the market licensing--
sorry, private key is in
the market licensing server,
and the public key
is actually in our server.
It's no longer even
in our application.
And now what happens is
we check the license request,
send it off to the server,
and it comes back.
And our application,
instead of doing anything
with that signed response,
actually sends it
up to the server.
And at this point the server
is actually responsible
for doing any validation,
and it actually sends,
in this case,
a session token
back to the application,
which can then be used
to download whatever you like.
Sounds pretty cool.
Once again,
now it doesn't even matter
if the application itself
is compromised.
Ultimately what we're really
doing is proxy-ing
a transaction
between two servers,
your server and our server.
Now there is one potential
problem with this
and that is, of course,
replay attacks.
We want to avoid replay attacks.
We want to make sure
that someone
can't just capture
one of these sessions
and use it to download the files
and embed it back
into the application.
So the good news is that we have
something called the nonce
in a license validation
transaction.
And you've got
a couple of options
for how you might want
to use that.
Um, you can generate it
on your server,
and you can store
all the nonce values,
and that allows you to guarantee
that each one of these
license validation checks
is only used once,
and you're always going to have
to use a fresh one
in order to validate
the license on an application.
The other thing you can do
is generate it on the client
and have the server
store it afterwards.
A little bit more--a little bit
harder to deal with
in terms of security,
uh, because you, in theory,
could have collisions,
but it's highly unlikely.
So another thing,
as I alluded to earlier,
is we can change
the monetization model--
and, you know, a lot of this
is about games,
but this applies
to all applications as well--
so, of course, considering free
versions that are upgradeable,
using game mechanics,
you know, gamify
actually the game play
so that we can actually
drive people into content,
and of course, providing things
that extend the game
and make a premium experience.
So let's talk a little bit
about Android Market
In-app Billing.
Now this is a great feature.
We announced it and released it
just a few months ago,
and we've seen great uptake
with it already.
It allows you to purchase
virtual goods and consumables.
And again, we allow--we can do
both client-side
and server-side validation.
So our managed items are things
like your application.
They're things that can
only be purchased once.
But the good news
is that your application
can actually ask the server
to replay these items,
and they're really designed
for applications
that don't necessarily
have a server component.
And in fact,
you can even set it up
so that if someone buys an item
on one instance
of an application
you make it show up
on another instance
of the application
on another device automatically,
but you don't have to do that.
Unmanaged items are SKUs in
Market like your application,
but they can be purchased
multiple times,
and your application
cannot ask for a replay,
so these are harder to secure.
It--it--it--having
your own server
is really, really useful
in all of these cases
but especially in the case
of unmanaged items.
So how does this look?
Well, at a high level,
it actually looks
almost exactly the same
as what we did with
the license validation library.
We have the private key
sitting in the Market server,
and the public key
in our application.
And we send a request off.
It signs it with that key.
It comes back, bam,
into our billing receiver.
The server version
is almost identical.
Once again, at a high level
this is what it looks like...
pretty straightforward.
Now one thing I'm doing here,
and I thought
I'd point this out,
is I'm adding credentials,
and this might be useful
if what we're trying to do
is actually support
account information
across multiple devices.
Ultimately what's going
to happen
is that this--this transaction
is going to end up getting an ID
that's generated by the server.
But in order to avoid any
possibility of replay attacks,
adding a credential
is actually useful.
And once again, now that
we have our server-side version,
we can do the same thing.
We can deliver new content
as the result of
an In-app Billing transaction.
But let's go
a little bit deeper here
because In-app Billing is
slightly more complicated to use
than license validation
for obvious reasons.
So here is
our application activity,
and here is Android Market.
And the way this works
is we start off
by requesting a purchase.
Now before you do this,
you should make sure
that you actually are
on a version of Android Market
that supports In-app Billing,
and there's a call to do that.
I'm not gonna go through that.
Then it ends up bundling
a response code
that includes a purchase intent,
and we are then
going to execute.
We're gonna invoke that
with a StartIntentSender
if we're on Android 2.0
or above,
and that causes the checkout UI
to get displayed
on top of our application,
and it actually comes up
as non-full screen activity,
which means that our application
then goes into onPause() state.
Now for those of you
who are writing games,
if you, at this point, go
and dump all of your textures,
you're going to--or you're using
the standard GLSurfaceView
that dumps all of your textures,
you're gonna find out
that it's gonna take
a couple seconds potentially
for this to come back
when you reload everything.
So you might want to take
a look at this case
and optimize around it,
so in fact we don't necessarily
dump until onStop().
Then the user's gonna actually
say they buy something,
and we get
an activity onResume()
followed by
a broadcast result code
saying what happened.
So then we--then we, of course,
say, "Well, what did they buy?"
We get the information,
and it comes back
in a broadcast.
Now the key thing
about these operations
is that the first section here,
the request purchase
and that bundle,
are synchronous.
After that, these are entirely
asynchronous operations.
So it means that you have
to think about it
when you're writing
your application.
You have to make sure
that there's something
that the user knows,
that there's something still
going on in the background.
It may take a while.
We have fraud prevention and all
sorts of stuff on the back end
that we try to do to make sure
that the system
is working to its best,
but that can take some time.
So there is a delay
that will happen here.
Finally, at the end of this,
we get
a "purchase state changed"
that lets us know that
the purchase actually went
through or didn't go through.
And then we say to the server,
"Yes, I got that message,"
which is important,
because if we don't actually
confirm the notification
the server's gonna try to keep
delivering that notification
to us again and again and again
until we confirm it,
which is very, very useful,
because your application
could get killed
in the middle of this,
and you want to make sure
that when your application
is up and running,
it actually gets a notification,
confirms it, so you actually
purchase the item,
give the user what they--
what they bought.
And then finally
it lets you know
that it received
your confirmation.
So that's how you do it
without a server component.
In order to add
a server component to this
it's pretty straightforward.
We're gonna use the technique
in which the server
actually generates the nonce.
So we're gonna start off with
sending a request to our server
to get that nonce
and getting that nonce back.
And then when we actually go
to confirm the notification,
what we're actually going to do
is perform the server
billing side authentication
on our server,
send it--send it the credentials
that it's gotten back
from Market,
and then finally return
the validated
that we've routed
to the billing response.
Now in our particular example,
all that we've done
is actually taken a session ID
that we generated earlier
and validated it
and--and Trevor's gonna be
demonstrating that
in just a moment.
So, Trevor, if you could
come up, actually. [laughs]
Johns: Okay, so if we can switch
over to our project here...
Galpin: Yes.
Johns: Which I think
is number three.
Galpin: Sounds good.
Johns: Ah, there we go.
All right, so this is
a small little demo app
that me and Dan have been
working on,
um, to go and demonstrate
all this.
We'll be releasing the code, um,
sometime after the--
after Google I/O is--
after Google I/O is over
for all of you to download
and take a look at.
But basically
it just goes through
exactly what
we just talked about.
So I have my, uh, nice
little downloader app here.
You can tell that the UI's
very, very awesome, right?
[laughs]
Um, and we implemented both
techniques you can use here,
either, um, checking
a license server certificate
or through In-App Billing.
So we're gonna show you
In-App Billing here.
And so when I push that,
two things are happening
behind the scenes here,
assuming Wi-Fi works.
First off we're going to go
and get that nonce,
and then we go,
and as soon as we get that,
we make our In-App Billing
request.
So let's go ahead and buy this
with my nice
fake credit card here.
All right.
That comes back.
Um, you see a slight delay
there while we wait for Market
to go and confirm everything
for us,
and then we get
a "Download Content" button.
And so when we push
"Download Content" here,
two more things
are gonna happen.
First, we're gonna go
and take all of this time data
that Market sent us
and send it back to the server.
The server's gonna go
and upgrade our session token,
and then we're gonna go
and start downloading
our files...
if Wi-Fi works. [laughs]
So, um, ah, and there you go.
So I could go into the Market--
uh, Publisher Console
and go--instead of--instead of
a-a license response--
or a purchase response,
we can go and set it to, um,
send us--Excuse me.
Since this is In-App Billing
I can go and change the test SKU
and say that we're--
that the purchase
didn't go through,
but I'm not gonna do that,
'cause, quite frankly,
it's not that interesting.
Nothing happens.
Everything stops.
Which is exactly what you want,
right.
And so when this
finishes downloading,
which, um, probably will take
another minute here,
so I'm not gonna bore you all,
we get a nice little video file.
You can click "play,"
and you'll get a nice app
of all the Android app--all
the Android--er, activations.
So, um...
Galpin: So this is an example--
yeah, I should
probably continue on.
Um, so this--we're not gonna
switch to the slides.
I do want to actually show that.
But what's kind of cool
about this
is this is actually
a sample that we wrote
that takes the original source
code that was given in both
the license validation library
and the In-App Billing library
and actually ports it
to standard Java SE,
and it's running on--
under App Engine.
Johns: Correct.
Galpin: And, uh,
and we're actually playing...
Johns: Yay.
Galpin: One of
my favorite videos.
Um, actually all the time.
Johns: So like Dan said,
the important thing to note here
is this is the same source code
you have as part
of the Android SDK.
And since it's Java code,
and App Engine
also supports Java,
we can pretty easily
just go and copy that over,
and it actually doesn't take
too much work to get it working.
Galpin: That's right.
Even Trevor and I can do it,
which means all of you
can do it.
Johns: Yep. Right.
Let's go back to the slides.
Maybe. There we go.
Galpin: All right. There we are.
Okay, so let's talk
just a little bit
about App Engine,
and App Engine has been
really good to us,
because we needed a place where
we could host that Java code
and do that validation
and also, in this case,
host the buying that
we're actually downloading.
So, of course, it allows you
to run your Java code
on our infrastructure.
In this case we're using it
to validate license responses,
secure transactions,
and serve files directly
from the Blobstore.
And--and what we're actually
doing is there's actually
three different programs
in action here.
There's actually
an App Engine application,
which is handling
almost everything.
There's actually a small
python script that we wrote
that actually does bulk
uploading into App Engine
and stores things
in the Blobstore.
And then, of course, there's
the Android side module,
which we just demonstrated.
And again, this is useful
as an example.
But remember, this is
just standard code.
It can be run on
any Java-capable server.
So how do we create
an App Engine project?
So I'm gonna go through this
very, very quickly,
but it is very, very easy
specially if you like
using Eclipse,
or if you just have Eclipse.
You can just install
the plug-in.
You can then literally
go through this wizard,
which will create
the App Engine project for you,
and it creates a little servlet
that you can fill in.
And then you can literally
launch that servlet
by going and clicking
"Deploy to App Engine."
It really is pretty much
that simple.
And we give you a bunch of tools
to manage it as well.
You can look at bandwidth.
You can see
who's connecting to it.
It's kind of cool. You can
also get log-in information.
But let's look at what the code
actually was like on App Engine.
So now admittedly this is not--
I'm not gonna show
the entire ported code,
'cause it would take
a long time.
It would bore you even more.
So what I am gonna do
is show you the module
that actually handles
the request for data
and does the validation.
So all this--all this
is doing here
is actually gonna
generate a session.
And what we're doing here
is we're actually getting
the signature from the device,
and we're passing it
through that same
licensed validator class
that is part of the LVL.
We're calling verified just
like we would do on the device,
and then we're returning
that value
as part of a new session token
which is now validated.
Now again, you know,
this is just an example
of how one can build
this kind of server,
but it's pretty straightforward.
There's a very small amount
of code
that needs to be
actually written.
So while I have you all here,
let me talk a little bit
about Cloud services in general.
So your application
actually can take advantage
of Cloud to Device Messaging,
which is, of course,
basically what we're using
for the background
for Google Talk and for GMAIL
to send messages.
Also, the backup service.
And then, of course, in that--
in that other pile
we have Android Market,
licensing and billing,
which I've talked about here.
So Cloud to Device Messaging--
we announced it last year
at Google I/O.
It's pretty cool.
It launches your app
if it's not running.
It leverages
our network connection,
and it queues
and delivers messages.
And it's pretty straightforward
to set up,
and I'll go through
a real basic flow here.
And the reason why
I'm bringing these things in
as part of this application
is these are all part of bunch
of Cloud services
you can take advantage of
in your application.
And I think it's important,
especially now that we're seeing
such an enormous number--
percentage of devices
that are running Froyo,
that people, for example, start
to take advantage of C2DM.
We're at over 65% of devices now
that are running Froyo.
So basically we start
with the registration flow.
It's pretty simple.
Your application needs to
register itself with the server,
and your application
has to forward that idea across.
Then on the back end side
your server actually
has to create
and store a session
with Cloud to Device Messaging
and finally return the response.
After that point, you can send
messages to the service,
and it's going to send intents
to your application,
Pretty straightforward.
Application data backup
is kind of interesting as well.
Um, one of the things that--
that I found
is really frustrating
is that I move around
between Android devices a lot.
I don't know how many
of you do that,
but I find I do it
more than most probably.
And it's really frustrating
if I'm playing a title
or playing a game,
or if I even have settings,
and they don't end up
getting transferred
automatically between devices.
And of course, we provide
that capability
with application data backup,
and I want more applications
to use it.
It also can be used for
a couple of cool ideas.
Like if you want
to be able to track things
going across devices,
you can actually have that same
session carried across devices
with application data backup.
And this flows pretty
straightforward as well.
You basically tell
the backup manager
when you have data
that has changed.
It then gives you
an onBackup() request,
and it backs things up
to the Cloud.
Now obviously, um,
uh, you know,
if you look at this,
this is actually part
of the framework.
This is actually not tied
to Android Market,
so you're relying on
whatever Cloud backup
infrastructure is on the device.
Restoring is pretty much
straightforward as well.
If the application is installed,
if data is backed up,
it will send you an onRestore().
So it's pretty straightforward,
and it allows you
to do a lot of things,
and it can also help you track
what's going on
with usage across users.
So one more thing--
if you like the Androids
in this presentation,
please consider
Androidifying yourself.
It's really fun.
And it saved me a lot of time
making artwork.
[laughter]
Galpin: So, uh, now we're gonna
open up the floor for questions.
Now please use the microphones
so that people outside
of this room can hear you
or maybe even so that people
inside of this room can hear,
and Trevor and I can both
take your questions.
Thank you.
[applause]
man: So if you're
doing something--
like you mentioned you're
downloading this large movie.
You don't want them
to download the movie
and then just send it
to all their friends.
Are you doing that
by virtue of putting that
in the application store?
Galpin: Well, you know, you've
got a couple of options here.
I mean, I think that--
I think in this particular case
we want to stop them from using
bandwidth on our server.
Our goal was not to actually try
to protect the content.
That's a secondary thing.
Now, of course, you can take
that content, whatever it is.
You can encrypt it
however you like.
You can get a lot
of per device data there,
and you can do that
on your back end.
But that's kind of
a secondary problem
versus the problem
of just trying
to prevent someone from leeching
off your bandwidth, which is
what we were, in this case,
particularly talking about.
man: Okay. Um, and if you don't
have your own server,
the Android Market
doesn't have any mechanism
for storing binaries.
You need to kind of
create your own server for that.
Galpin: Well, as far as
what's tied in In-App Billing,
that's correct.
At the moment we do not have
anything like that.
But again we do have things
like App Engine.
App Engine has a certain amount
of free quota,
and it's, you know--
so there are ways in which,
depending on how much data
you have to store,
you can still find facilities
out there on the Web,
whether it's through us
or through someone else.
man: Okay. Thank you.
Galpin: Sure.
Coryat: Yes,
my name's John Coryat.
I have a free app
called Radar Now.
Um, I have, like, uh,
about a million,
um, active users,
and implementing, like, license
checks and stuff like that,
I'm not sure if that's good
for a free app.
I'd like to implement
In-App Billing,
but, you know, that's adding
another layer.
What's your feeling on that?
Galpin: Well, so license--
I should have made this clear
at the start.
So license validation
is something
that only applies
to a paid application.
Coryat: Okay.
Galpin: And, uh,
and as far as In-App Billing
is concerned, um, you know,
I think that, uh, if it fits
the business model,
you know, I-I think
it can make sense.
You know, obviously
you have to have something
to drive someone to it.
If you do use In-App Billing,
and you're doing an app
that's not server-driven,
I'd definitely recommend using
a lot of these same checks
we were talking about
in terms of integrity,
because, again, that now
becomes a surface area
for someone to attack, so, uh--
but for a free application
it's typically not something
that's required.
Coryat: Yeah, so what I have
in mind is adding features
that have been requested
over the last two years
by users begging for new stuff
and, uh...
Galpin: Mm-hmm.
Coryat: And the In-App Billing
thing seems perfect.
I want to implement
in a subscription roll
on my own server.
Galpin: Mm-hmm.
Coryat: That's no issue, right?
Galpin: So the only issue with
In-App Billing and subscriptions
is there's currently no support
for subscriptions.
in our In-App Billing directly,
but you can use it
as an unmanaged item,
and you can manage
those transactions yourself.
So you can just notify the user
that their subscription's
running out.
They have to do
another purchase.
Coryat: Very good.
Thanks very much.
Galpin: Sure.
man: I would like
to ask a question.
Once you have pirated apps
out there, um,
and so then you can implement
the LVL and stuff,
but other than coming out with
new updates with great features,
is there anything else
that you can do
with things that are out there
in the wild?
Galpin: Um, if you don't have
a server component, it's tough.
I mean, you know, obviously--
obviously, um, my general--
my general feeling
is that it's useful
for every application
to have some kind
of server component if possible,
even if that's just
for analytics.
I think it's important
for applications to track--
for developers to know who's
using their applications,
where they are, what kind
of install rate they're getting,
even beyond what they get from
Market, which is pretty good.
But that--so my feeling is,
yeah, it's hard.
I mean, once it's--once it's
truly out there,
there's not a lot you can do,
so...
Stone: Hi, my name is Bo Stone.
I do DroidIn for LinkedIn.
It's a first-ever LinkedIn app.
Galpin: Mm-hmm.
Stone: Um, and here's
the question.
Uh, I have a pro version
of the app,
and all it really does
is removes the ads,
you know, Google ad, um,
from--from the application,
so I would like going forward
to make it available as, um,
basically in-Market purchase,
In-App purchase.
Galpin: Mm-hmm.
Stone: But what's
really stopping me
is that, uh, what do I do with
all the custom--
all my happy customers
that already have it?
So if I remove that code that,
you know, that I already have
for verifying the license,
what are they gonna do
with my future releases?
And so if you don't have that,
I mean,
I treat it as a request.
I just need a mechanism of
taking that existing license
and maybe giving
my customers a voucher
that they can basically then go
into a Market site
and purchase--
basically use it to--to convert
that license
into In-App license.
Galpin: Right.
I mean, I think, so I mean--
so the only way to do that
right now with the system
is--is for it to be
an unmanaged transaction
for you to store that kind
of information on your server.
'Cause that gives you
all the flexibility
to control how you use it.
So you know, put up a--
if you put up a little server,
and you tack on there, it's
still not a perfect solution,
and I'd like to support that,
honestly,
but, uh, you know, right now
the only way you can do that
is through
an unmanaged transaction.
Stone: All right, thank you.
Galpin: Sure.
man: Um, yes, hello.
In terms of, like--
this was mainly for,
let's say, paid apps
or In-App transaction.
But for instance, if I want
to just save some information
and want to obfuscate it,
let's say,
like an API token...
Galpin: Right.
man: and sometimes
a secret as well,
is there any best practice?
I mean, would you recommend
a way to ensure
we can obfuscate some data
that's either specific
to a user,
like, uh, some kind of
passwords,
something of that sort...
Galpin: Mm-hmm.
man: or a token, in a way
that makes it difficult
to just achieve easily,
and where would--
where would you place it?
Galpin: Well,
I mean, ultimately--
so, I mean, ultimately I guess
there's kind of two things.
If you're trying to protect
the user's data
from other applications,
the platform does a pretty good
job of doing that already,
um, as long as you store data
in private locations,
you know, and that's--
and that's one of the places
in which the platform really
tries to secure data.
Um, and of course, obfuscating
things on top of that is good,
uh, uh, because, of course,
the platform
could be compromised.
There's no such thing
as a perfect system.
But, um, but in general
that's--that's the--
the platform tries
very, very hard
to make sure that
there is a sandbox
that applications can't get
out of to make that happen.
Um, as far as best practices
in general for obfuscating,
I mean, I think that, uh,
you know, some of the things
we talked about here
are--are not exactly relevant
to actually obfuscating data.
But if you look inside
of the LVL,
there's actually an obfuscated
preferences module
that we actually give you
a source code,
and that's probably
a good place to start.
And it includes--it includes
a pretty straightforward
implementation of that,
and you can certainly grab
that code and use it.
It's part of the freely
available library.
man: Okay, and just as
a continuation of that,
would you always execute
some kind of--
I suppose you have to--
but obfuscation and all
this kind of processing power
just every time you need
to access it?
So for instance if you have
like a [speaking indistinctly]
where you want to know
if the user is logged in,
do you each time
have to execute,
let's say, this entire process
of running a thread
and you know...
Galpin: I mean--
I mean, I think that
it really depends on--on
whether it's gonna
adversely affect
the performance of your app.
If it's not,
then I see no reason
why not to execute it
all the time.
If it does, then obviously
you're gonna want to make
a compromise between
some level of security
and some level of performance.
I think it's really
on an app-by-app basis.
man: Okay, thank you.
man: Hi.
Galpin: Oh, yeah.
man: My question
is on the free apps.
You know, free apps...
[speaking indistinctly]
the license validation check,
right?
But I still want to do
the vampire attack.
You know, some unknown people
are taking my free app
and start using
my service site resources.
So how do I go about protecting
that kind of, you know,
free apps but at the same time
vampire attacks?
Galpin:
It's an interesting problem.
I mean, I guess--
I guess the question is,
you know, in general
with the free app
the goal is to have
as many users as possible,
so are people misusing your app
in some way,
or is it--or...
man: Yeah.
For example, take the code
and decompile and, you know,
modify certain things...
Galpin: Right.
man: and make it work
on some other device,
which we really don't want
to work on certain device.
Galpin: I see. I see.
Yeah, I mean, you know,
in that case,
LVL isn't really gonna help you
because ultimately the thing to
do is focus on integrity checks
and try to make sure
that the code is--is
as functionless as possible
in those cases,
and you know, make sure that--
you know, if someone's
touched your code,
a lot of those things will
really make it very challenging
for them to--to get
your application to work.
And you know, hopefully
they'll give up,
but if they don't,
you know, that's--that's--
at least hopefully you've
prevented--you've created
a window of opportunity
for your application.
Now if you're using--
if you're talking about using
server-side resources,
a lot of the things you can do
are actually take things like--
encrypt pieces.
One of the things that's
very successful, actually,
is taking, um, pieces of
your code that are well-known
and using them as keys that
you send up to your encrypt--
up to your server.
So do things like grab
the CRC of this
and don't necessarily use it
for an integrity check,
but actually use it as a key
that the server ends up using
to send content.
So that's another method.
You can actually directly
incorporate integrity checks
into helping prevent misuse
of your application.
Johns: Yeah, and it's
also worth noting, I mean,
what you're trying
to do ultimately
when you're trying to do
an application integrity check
is make sure nobody's
tampered with the system.
And to do that, you really need
something like a DPM,
which unfortunately Android
doesn't have support for.
Um, who knows.
At some point in the future
we may or may not get that,
but really that's
the missing piece
for what you're trying
to do there.
Galpin: But the key thing,
I think, is, you know, again,
you can take advantage of values
that come from integrity checks,
things like the CRC, things like
your application signature,
things that are very difficult
to tamper with and use those
as--and send them directly
to your application
and use those to actually
validate what's going on.
Now again, all this stuff
can be spoofed.
It's not a perfect system,
but you can make it
pretty challenging
for someone to figure out
what's going on.
man: Continuation on that,
you said that application
can proxy the, you know,
encrypted data coming from
the Android Market
and then send it to our server
in the back end.
Galpin: Mm-hmm.
man: But what server has to do
at that point, you know,
how do they validate
the response?
Galpin: So ultimately it's what
I was talking about before.
The Android Market signs
everything with a, um,
with a private key,
and then so what you do
is you put the public key
that's associated
with that private key--
and we give that to you
on Android Market.
You put that on your server,
and you actually use that
to validate the signature
that comes back in
from Android Market.
So that's how it creates
a relatively secure channel
between the Market
and your application,
even though the Market server
isn't directly talking
to your server.
man: Oh, thank you.
Johns: Yeah, and a take a look
in the In-App Billing code.
There's a security Java file
that shows you exactly how
to validate that response,
and the source code
we'll be releasing
will show you how to do that.
Galpin: Yeah, exactly.
man: In the sample project
that you created,
did you actually take the time
to decompile your own
application and try to hack it?
And in that case, which methods
did you find were easier
to circumvent than others?
Galpin: So--
Johns: This one in particular--
um, well, to answer the first
part of your question, yes.
man: Okay.
John: But in this case
since we're doing
service side validation,
there's actually no attack
window on the device,
um, 'cause really
what you're doing
is validating
a signed piece of data
that's coming
from the Market server.
So assuming that
you can't tamper with
the Market server code,
which hopefully you can't,
um, and assuming nobody can
tamper with your server,
um, you know,
all the actual validation
is being done on those ends,
and the device itself
is just acting as a conduit for
the two to talk to each other.
man: That applies to
your In-App purchasing example.
Johns: Right.
Galpin: And the LVL example
as well.
What's more interesting
is when you get into
the anti-tampering examples.
And so there actually are tools
out there
that you can actually run, uh,
and, uh,
there are--there are
some Web sites
that have created some
fairly sophisticated tools
that try to break
this kind of protection.
So that'd be my first--
my first effort on that.
And, yeah, I actually designed
some of these examples
based upon the results
of that tool.
Now, of course, the tool
is gonna get updated,
so don't use
my examples verbatim.
Uh, but, uh, but definitely
that's a good place to start.
The last thing you want
is for you to put a lot of work
into something
and to have it immediately
get--get compromised.
man: I also have
a follow-up question.
Um, what are your thoughts on
third-party libraries,
such as Urban Airship,
and the services they provide
versus how basically
it's essentially copy and paste
for every application?
Galpin: Uh...
man: Are you familiar?
Galpin: I'm not.
I don't have enough familiarity
with what they're doing.
man: Basically they handle
the server-side validation,
and you drop it
into your application,
and they provide
the transport mechanism
for the content to your device.
Galpin: Mm-hmm.
I've heard--I've seen
some things like that.
Yeah, I don't really have
an opinion on it.
If they work, that's great.
It's not--again, we're just
trying to show you
how to use the APIs to do it.
man: Right.
Galpin: But if they're doing it
for you, that's awesome.
man: And what is the best way
to use In-App Payments
for opening
some extra premium features
of the application?
Because in this case you will--
you should have all this code
also inside the application,
and an attacker can use
all those techniques to open it.
Galpin: So my--my general
best practice on that
is to try to have resources
that are not in your application
that have to be pulled in
from a server.
And if that--and even better
if they can be encrypted
with some
device-specific information
that makes it a lot harder for
someone to break it and use it,
especially if that decryption
is being done,
like, inside of native code,
or it's being--
you know, for
a lot of game titles,
that's actually very, very easy.
That's how they're already
accessing those assets.
So that would be one way
if you want to actually put--
put a little bit more, um, uh,
to make it a little bit harder,
a little bit more obfuscated.
So I-I like that method.
Um, there are plenty
of other methods, too.
I mean, um, if you look at
the latest versions of Unity.
Um, they--they actually do
a bunch of things
to try to help people out
in this exact same way,
uh, in order to help them
encrypt resources
and unlock things
in the application.
But I think the best practice
is to actually download
something else additional
to the application.
man: Even DEX files
to the memory?
Galpin: Um, the problem with
DEX--DEX files are interesting.
The problem with DEX files
is that you can't, um,
you can't actually encrypt them
because they have to--
and they have to be loaded in
the internal file system.
You can't actually load them
from memory
with our class loader.
So, um, yes, that's not--
that's not a bad idea
if it's a small class
that does something integral,
but it--it is--it doesn't
necessarily provide you
that much protection,
and it is a lot of work
to set up.
And it also is something that,
you know,
in general downloading code
is sort of
a questionable practice
even though it does,
um, it does--
even though the--the actual
system will prevent it
from getting to any resources
that your application
hasn't already--
hasn't already asked for.
It does provide--
it does mean that your app
is ultimately responsible for
a potential additional vector
for compromising the system.
So as a general rule,
you know, yes, um,
it's one way of doing things,
but it does mean that your
application could potentially
be used by something else
that's naughty
if it can figure out how you're
dealing with that DEX file.
man: Okay, thanks.
man: Hi, Dan.
I--why not close the loop
and have the Market server
communicate with your server?
Johns: [laughs]
Galpin: It's--it's--
it's something that
I think would be--
would be an excellent addition
to the API.
I don't think cryptographically
it's required.
Uh, but I think
that it would make--
it would make life
a little bit easier
for some--for some applications,
and it's something
that certainly we've talked
to the Market team about.
Johns: Yeah, so just to follow
up on that and to be clear--
from a security perspective,
the way we're doing it
versus providing an additional
API on the market server
that your app could talk to,
they're essentially equivalent.
Um, the downside is having
an additional API
actually adds
one more round trip worth
of latency to your--
to your check.
Um, but again, there are
some--some specific cases
where it might make life easier
on developers,
so we--we definitely have
a feature request open for that.
man: All right, thanks.
Galpin: All right, well,
if that's it for the questions,
the next session here
is going to be on, uh,
bringing your games to Android
with C and C++,
and myself and Ian Lewis
are gonna present that.
And let us know how we're doing.
I had a speaker meter,
uh, URL up there.
And so please, uh, do check in.
We do actually listen
to your feedback.
And if you thought this was
a giant waste of time,
let us know,
and if you thought it was
interesting, let us know.
And we'll be back next
with "Bringing Games to Android
with C and C++."
Thank you.
[applause]